hey everybody time again for the movie
retrospective the one we're gonna be
talking about people want to do this one
for a long time because I [ __ ] love
this movie and I feel like it's one that
kind of gets overlooked a lot
it's a weird movie it's really weird if
that's what that's and so I'm gonna say
right now that it's like it's kind of
hard to talk about this movie without
spoiling it yeah so I'm gonna spoil it
so like if you you know if you want to
see it and you've never seen it yeah
then I think it's better to go into it
not knowing what's coming it's a very
old-school 70s movie it it has when it
starts off you kind of think it's
comment when those hard-boiled police
detective movies yeah um where do we see
it know what's on shutter sound shutter
you don't shudder yeah it was it's a
good copy it's a very good cop finally
um
you find out there's a lot more to you
think it's about people going crazy
seeing God and killing people mm-hmm but
you find that was a lot more to it than
that it's kind of about that yeah and it
goes off in a direction you don't expect
yeah but what was weird is that it is a
very ballsy movie for its time oh it
definitely is it was you know other
people copied these ideas a long time a
long time after this I saw a lot of this
in other movies they say oh that's where
they got this and that's where they got
that but it's a good movie it's it's
it's old-school it looks kind of
low-budget it is low budget yeah but
it's it has quite a big scope and there
ends up being some practical effects in
it that kind of look like something out
of the 80s not quite not quite as good
as say from beyond but along that lines
kind of like yeah a little bit a weird
like body or body hoard yeah yeah I'm
gonna say now this came out in you know
it's called God told me to also it was
released under the name demon for some
[ __ ] reason I don't know why because
I guess some people thought the title
was offensive so when they released it
they released at the different name so
you might have seen it at that name it
was directed by the info
Larry Cohen who if you don't know who
that is he he actually died I think just
earlier this year maybe last spring
unfortunately but um probably best known
for stuff like he did it's alive he did
the stuff cue the wing it serpent
Maniac Cop so he's he's like a you know
a very well known cult filmmaker and the
weird thing about God told me to is I
feel like it says maybe one of his least
known even though I think it's his best
movie yeah when you comparing it to make
you the wicked serpent it's a lot better
than that now I love Q the way it survey
but I like this one a lot better this
one was almost kind of like a very
old-school Cronenberg movie that's what
it felt like - yeah it does like I do
have a little bit of brood or something
it kind of like okay the thing about it
is then like I said I'm gonna spoil it
so you know if you haven't done it I saw
this like I had seen a bunch of Larry
Cohen's other movies like I'd seen it's
alive and the stuff and all that other
kind of stuff but then like I kept
seeing God told me to like coming up in
all these like underrated horror lists
and I'm like [ __ ] man it's like I like
Larry Cohen and I've never seen that one
I actually found like a kind of a shitty
free copy on YouTube it might still be
there I don't know but um but recently
when shudder put it up I was like really
excited cuz I was like well now I can
see it you know looking a lot better
than the shitty crappy copy that I
initially saw and I liked it a lot
better but so the thing about this movie
is that at the very beginning it it kind
of hits the ground running it's like
pretty much the very first scene is just
people walking through New York City and
then suddenly getting plugged by a
sniper and it turns out that this guy
who's like a sniper he's like way up on
top of this water tower and our
protagonist who is a police detective by
the name of Peter Nicholas who's played
by Tony
LoBianco he decides he's gonna climb up
there and kind of you know try to talk
to the guy and see what the [ __ ] deal
is and all this other kind of stuff and
this is when you find out that this guy
is just going around plugging people and
he's just like super calm about it and
everything and he's he's like well why
did you do it are you upset about
something he's like no I'm not upset
about anything he's like God told me to
yeah so
as the story progresses and like I said
pretty much the first half to two-thirds
of this movie plays out pretty much like
a police procedural it has aspects of
the Exorcist in that it's very Catholic
because you know the main protagonist
the detective is like really really
religious and so he kind of gets sucked
into these crimes because you know the
first guy who's the sniper and he says
God told God told me to and then they
start seeing like all these other kind
of mass murders like the next one is
like this guy who just like goes on a
mass stabbing like inside the inside a
supermarket you know somebody kills
their whole family and all this other
kind of [ __ ] like just for no reason and
every single one of them when asked why
they do it they're just very calm about
it and they just say oh well God told me
to like you know like it's the most
normal thing in the world
so because detective Nicholas is so
religious he starts to get like kind of
fascinated with are these people really
is God really talking to these people
because he's kind of having he's he's
kind of like in the same position I
guess is like father Karras and The
Exorcist
where he's kind of like having a crisis
of faith type of thing yeah this reminds
me of another movie - there's another
movie that kind of had that same kind of
like what was that movie about I had the
guy it had the guy from aliens - and it
was a Christian movie and they were
going out and abducting people and
killing them and he was saying these are
people are demons frailty frailty we did
a review of that yeah and one of the
sons could see it but the other sudden
couldn't see it yeah it comes off kind
of a feeling like that in a way yeah I'm
like that happening you don't either
that's what I thought but I don't know
it's kind of cool it's kind of a
Cronenberg movie in a certain way and
then another way that some of the tone
count to me almost reminded me of
remembered remember - liquid sky yeah
yeah yeah yeah these weirdest parts of
it was like kind the the feeling I got
was kind of like the feeling I got from
some of the really good scenes in liquid
sky was spotty
yeah it is but it's like some
it's like it was pieced together you
know the man something that was a lot
better than the other stuff in the end
it wasn't all that good and it was just
it was a it was an art film you know oh
yeah they're just having fun felt making
films with their club friends yeah and
it didn't go exactly in the direction I
thought was going to but this one is
almost caught there's certain well I
don't want to do any sport but no I
already said we're gonna spoil were
there there's a UFO theme and liquid sky
- yeah
turns out that it's God's tell him to do
it but in this movie God's ancient
aliens pretty much yeah and Larry Cohen
also write the script of this so he said
that he actually got the idea from
reading the Bible and it occurring to
him that God was like one of the most
violent characters in all of literature
and also about the whole like Chariots
of the Gods type of stuff that was very
big in the 70s where you know ancient
aliens came and like helped ancient
people like do this that the other thing
and that um maybe like the reason why
there's so many similarities and
religions and whatnot is because but
these aliens visited yeah there's
another way to look at it though I mean
if you look at the Old Testament in the
New Testament the kingdom of heaven and
heaven and God and all his sons that
came down from heaven to choose tribes
they're talking about heaven is the
space yeah it's the sky sky people you
know they're seeing clouds and different
layers of clouds so there must be
different levels of heaven and you know
yaver and you know and you know yaver is
a lightning God and a way or a storm God
so really if you if you if you take old
and new Testament stuffs which is like
Genesis if you take it literally
it's about aliens yeah spiritual aliens
or alien gods or things not from this
world
they're things from space they're
talking about and I call it heaven but
this movie takes that connection very
literally literally yeah in the sense
that and like I said I kind of love the
way this plays out like
an investigation like it's almost like
an investigation because when all these
mass murders happen oh and I should note
too that there's one that happens at
like the st. Patrick's Day parade like
through New York City and the cop or the
person that's dressed as a cop that goes
on the shooting spree that's Andy
Kaufman y'all and this was his first hmm
film appearance yeah so if you're
watching the movie go hey that looks
like Andy Kaufman it's because it is
yeah but yeah so so he starts getting
kind of like fascinated because like I
said he's very like very Catholic and
he's riddled with Catholic guilt even
though he has like all these layers as a
character because I guess he's still
married to his wife although I suppose
they're separated because they don't
live together and he has a girlfriend
like who's a lot younger and he's almost
he's not like shoving it in her face or
anything but it's all very open but the
weird thing about it is that he says
he's telling the girlfriend that he
can't marry her because his very
Catholic wife won't let him divorce her
but really it's him that's super
Catholic and is like weird about
divorcing everything so he's like I said
he gets because he has all of this
religious faith crisis going on he gets
super fascinated by all of these mass
murders happening around New York City
and why all these people are saying God
told me to and so he just starts
investigating investigating and during
one of the investigations he finds out
that one of the people that went on a
shooting spree had been seen hanging out
with this hippie looking guy they said
it's it they said it was this guy and he
was like walking around barefoot and he
had like really really long blonde hair
but the creepy thing is that no one
can't remember what his face looks like
like everybody says I don't know it was
just a blur you know what I mean so he
seems like some kind of weird figure so
it turns out as he investigates that a
couple of the other masters said yeah
they were hanging around with this guy
too so he finds out that this guy's name
is Bernard Phillips and he you know as
the investigation goes on he kind of
like finds out that the mom of this
person was evidently said that she was
she doesn't come out and say that
she was raped by extraterrestrials she
just says that she was walking down the
beach in Nantucket or something like
that and then she loses time and then
she was found in New Jersey like walking
down the street naked and then she found
out she was pregnant right
so essentially she's been impregnated by
an alien yeah so you find out that this
Bernard Phillips character he was like a
Jesus character but also kind of like a
demonic or like a satanic character also
he has like psychic powers and he can
like tell people to kill other people
for whatever his reason is I'm not
really sure what his endgame is but then
all that stuff kind of tied in with the
idea of the Demiurge yeah goes back to
the Old Testament you know and the Greek
understanding of the Old Testament where
if you have God and all his sons picking
tribes and giving and you know giving it
it's kind of like it's basically there
told me to Zeus and all in all his sons
you know and their mating with mortal
women to create Nephilim and that's the
same as creating demigods you know like
Perseus it's all that same idea whether
you take that literally then that means
you have gods and the sons of the gods
which are kind of like his aliens or
alien servants or whatever having sex
with mortal women to create half aliens
this is it and this also kind of goes up
the movie you know like the Anunnaki
you're kind of like Anunnaki and all
that kind of [ __ ] near narubu or near
Abu yeah which you know if you have
money and you have a big name you can
take an ideal like this and put a bunch
of special effects in it and basically
make Prometheus yeah which Prometheus
and alien covenants started getting into
this kind of stuff it's a good flick
it's just the way ahead of its time it's
trying to do a pretty sophisticated
story with not much money yeah well that
was kind of Larry Cohen's bag right and
um you know but I think he did a good
job but he did definitely with the
special effects that you know he did do
especially for the time
this really would have yeah this was
7576 this would have tripped people out
I think in 7576 because their I think
the average understanding of mythos is
amor or Bible mythos ism wasn't you know
most people didn't read the Bible that
way so they would have saw this very
sacrilegious oh yeah big time yeah they
would have said well that Bible doesn't
say that because well no in certain
passages if you read it literally that's
kind of what it's talking about yeah
things from the heavens meeting with
mortal women to create half alien
offspring yeah you know it says Nephilim
but that's that's aliens crossbreeding
with women yeah to make super beings
which that's kind of like the Greek gods
you know creating demigods like Perseus
and Hercules that's same [ __ ] but you
know they're not as pretty as an alien
well the thing I love about this one I'm
like you said I feel like it's like
really ahead of its time because I
because it goes in like it has like a
sci-fi element to it obviously because
of the whole ancient aliens and like
he's not even lower-body [ __ ] but it's
all like it's very very grounded in
reality right like I said it almost it
almost kind of gives me like an omen
kind of vibe to where it's like you know
it's yes it's supernatural but it all up
to that it pretty much seems like [ __ ]
that could kind of happen throughout you
know I mean like the way a shot it's
very matter-of-fact like sometimes when
an alien in this book the alien tries to
appear to you it kind of looks like it
takes the form of a kind of like the
Virgin Mary
you know it's using a bunch of religious
symbolism that maybe like a Catholic
would understand yeah but in this
particular case it might be like a man
that looks like the Virgin Mary but then
you find out actually it's like a
hermaphrodite alien that looks like the
Virgin Mary and it talks like the Virgin
Mary it's just weird
oh yeah because um the the alien the one
who's making all these people around the
city do this stuff like with his psychic
powers and stuff is kind of like the
head of this cult and there's all these
other people the cult they're usually a
little like older white dudes but this
guy
Barnard he like lives down in this
basement that's kind of like a psyche a
stand-in for hell I'm assuming because
there's like furnaces and [ __ ] and you
can't really like I said when people
look at him they can't really get a good
bead on him and even when um you know
detective Nicholas goes down to meet him
and he's just kind of bathed in this
yellow light he's played by Richard
Lynch you know is in like a [ __ ] ton of
movies back then and he is he's already
like discovered that he's already talked
to the doctor that delivered him as a
baby and found out that they thought it
was a virgin birth you know that the mom
was virgin they already found out that
the baby they couldn't tell what gender
it was so it's hermaphroditic or it's an
androgynous yeah that that actually I
forgot to actually said why to explain
why I was saying that what they were
talking about was the Demiurge the
ancient Greeks interpreted or nothing
yeah they're the Roman Romans and the
Greeks you know the ones that were you
know dealing with the New Testament when
they were first starting to put books
together that ended up being in the New
Testament one of the very early versions
of it was what was that guy's name he
wrote he put one of the first versions
of the Bible together it'll it only had
a couple of the book so their
interpretation of it was that the Old
Testament God was the Demiurge and which
was came from the plural which is where
the gods come from and it's the devil
god it's good and evil at the same time
yeah that's why I was doing all the kind
of stuff in the Old Testament that it
was doing but from the plural McKay
meone of it another son who was Jesus
who was a spiritual being that sat at
the right hand of this God but instead
of having to get to heaven by going
through the Demiurge or God's rules you
know hard ask difficult rules to follow
that are in the Old Testament you could
be saved by grace yeah through the faith
through Jesus and it had to do with
blood sacrifice through you know with
them there what do they call it
Pat during Passover which is you know
that's what the whole crew sufficient
seeing had to do with the basically
Jewish blood magic which is you know
scapegoat rituals and sacrificial lambs
yeah to wash away sin of the individual
or the tribe so basically when that when
you're seeing this God it might be good
and evil they're talking about the
Demiurge yeah it's not the jesus god
it's the it's the so-called real god or
the the devil god yeah the one that will
pass harsh harsh judgment on you it's
kind of above right and wrong and the
creepy thing about this too is that the
people that bernard psychically tells to
kill other people there's one great see
and i think probably the best scene in
this movie where this guy has
essentially just shot his entire family
he shot his wife and two little kids and
the detective is in there talking to him
like ask and he's just like telling and
he's just talking about it like it's
nothing and he's like and he's all happy
and beatific and everything and he's
like and he's like didn't he's like oh i
didn't have any way against him it just
occurred to me and like all this other
kind of [ __ ] in the old testament the
Demiurge you know God demanded the
sacrifice of the firstborn
it actually demanded human sacrifice it
wasn't until later that that got take it
that's what they're talking about there
yeah and that's what like I said so
there's there's a lot going on in this
movie so it's like as the thing goes on
so he finds out that Bernard Phillips is
essentially a half-alien because you
know he was and and he is able to do
like he has like godlike powers but the
creepy thing about it is that as the as
the investigation continues
Peter Nicholas is curious as to why
Bernard hasn't killed him or hasn't
tried to hurt him it's almost kind of
like he's doing all this to get his
attention or something like that so as
the detective is going through his own
history he finds out that his past
because he was raised in a Catholic
orphanage mirrors that of Bernard
Phillips he finds his birth mother and
who's played by the same woman that
played just that older lady
that was in beetlejuice her name's
Sylvia something um you know who was in
there with the she was like the
secretary not the secretary but she was
kind of like talking to the football
team and everything like that you know
it's like it's I'm not sure coach he
survived but if that lady so he goes and
sees her in a nursing home and she tells
him the same story that she was walking
home from like the World's Fair the New
York World's Fair in 1941 and she was
essentially abducted and she was like in
a ball of light and then she came back
and she found out that she was pregnant
and she had never had sex and all this
other kind of stuff so the detective
finds out that he is also half alien
it's just that he never knew it because
apparently his human genes like overrode
the alien ones they kind of have a
discussion about it at the end yeah so
when he finally meets up with Bernard at
the end Bernard is trying to get Peter
Nicholas to impregnate him he has a
vagina in his abdomen in case it's just
like here and his side like by his
ribcage like you do and so he's tried to
get Peter nicholas to impregnate him so
they can have like another race of so
this is a weird movie you guys because
like I said the first two-thirds of it
is just like a police procedural it's
like a police investigation oh it's
gonna go this way and you don't know
that it's going in this weird cycle like
there's a couple conversations like
somebody talking about ancient aliens
and somebody like mentioning that kind
of stuff but it's very grounded in
reality you know it's a very gritty 70
it's almost like Dog Day Afternoon or
main streets or something like it has
that kind of vibe going on so when it
just starts going into this like super
bizarre like sci-fi direction it's just
like super crazy and it's like so I can
see why at the time it didn't do very
well I mean plus you have to think - I
mean 1975-76 like a lot of really good
horror movies came out every thumbs
carry came out that you're the omen came
out that year so there was like a lot of
competition I guess and this one was
maybe just too weird for people yeah I
mean I feel like America would make some
weird [ __ ] you kind of shooting yourself
in your foot because if you have people
that are Christians they watch this they
think it's just you know
either just off the wall or real
sacrilegious yeah because they're
implying that that Jesus and Moses and
stuff like that were alien aliens
they're implying that and then if you
have people who are sci-fi fans that you
know they go oh man why'd they put that
Christian stuff in there that's how
they're gonna react to that yeah I guess
it's kind of like but but no it's
actually the movie was in a certain way
the concepts behind the movie are kind
of supported by certain ancient
interpretations of what the Old
Testament in the New Testament were
about I wish I could remember that that
guy's name I can't remember it was
during before the Bible was compiled
they had a guy in Rome who put a church
together and put a Bible together of
course the rest of the rest of the Roman
Christians didn't like it and then they
then they made the Bible we know of as a
response to that one yeah I got what
they were called it was the common one
of the first Christian denominations it
was like it was the only main difference
between it that Christianity and the
Christianity that you know today is is
that in that Christianity the Old
Testament God was the Demiurge it was
kind of a bad guy the the Jesus and his
version of the New Testament which is
compiled is mostly like Pauline epistles
was a Jesus that came from the plur Alma
it did sit at the right hand of it but
it wasn't um but was a good God was a
God of grace and that one never lived on
the earth yeah it was never born of a
woman and all that it was a celestial
Jesus I can't remember what they were
called yeah I used to use the word all
the time you talk about all time if I
was I forgot what they were now I'm
gonna look like a idiot on the video
what the hell is he talking about you
could go right here on Wikipedia and
they'll tell you about it it did exist
but that that form of Christianity is
gone I forgot what it was called though
yeah
but like I said it's it may seem like
this kind of like knockoff little cheap
b-movie but there's really a lot of like
really kind of deep ideas going on
behind this
I mean it's like so it's it's a really
interesting relic of the time I don't
know it just seemed like it didn't seem
like it got a lot of outrage at the time
it just seemed like it kind of came and
went
now there was kind of some controversy
about like the two guys that financed
the movie after they saw a cut of it
they said yeah well we gave you the
money but it's like just don't put our
names on it cuz I guess they like
thought it was offensive or whatever and
like I said when it didn't do very well
in the theater the first time it did
like a second run with the name demon
which I guess was trying to imply that
Bernard Phillips was like a bad guy
because people were offended by the
title God told me to because they were
seeing Bernard Phillips as God and even
in the movie it's like he's the villain
obviously but they're not really I mean
they're kind of playing with the whole
idea that maybe essentially he is a God
and you know what would that mean like
is there any way of proving if somebody
says they should they shoot up a bunch
of people and then they say Oh God told
me to well someone did tell them to
someone psychically told them to so
essentially God said yeah it's a very
it's a very unorthodox interpretation it
is Christianity and a lot of most people
know Orthodox Christianity but you know
there's a lot of accepted unorthodox
Christianity yeah and this is very much
like something based on old Gnosticism
wish I can't remember those guys names
but yeah
like for instance you know the Book of
Mormon is not Orthodox by say like a
Catholic point of view it's guys with
stories in there that they're just never
gonna find that that's only in the Book
of Mormon yeah but it doesn't matter
that's not where religions are about all
religions are unorthodox they're all
like that yeah orthodoxy is just a point
of view yeah and like I said I feel like
this particularly and I'm surprised that
more stuff didn't come out that was kind
of like this bit because it's kind of
like Chariots of the Gods
yeah but through maybe like a more
atheistic kind of lens or like a kind of
a cynical sort of lens because Larry
Cohen was like not down with the
religion so he was kind of like no he's
just looking fun at it I
a little bit I think he read some books
about Gnosticism he may have yeah and
and in the parallels between Chris
Christianity Judaism ancient ancient
Greek and Roman religions ancient all
ancient religions gonna have that
celestial family father of the gods
origin and all of his sons and all the
making of the demigods are all kind of
like that yeah and I think I think he
read some books that pointed out that
that's what the Old Testament and the
New Testament were about the creation of
demigods
yeah it's having children with mortal
people yeah to make Superman and
Nephilim Jesus was kind of like a
Nephilim in a way yeah ya know so like I
said there's a lot of that kind of [ __ ]
going on so he just showed it to you it
literally what that would be like if it
happen to happen yes and they're making
they're making children with mortal
that's aliens come coming down and cross
breeding with humans yeah to make half
humans and then like I said these past
these hybrids are essentially godlike
figures because they have godlike powers
and psychic abilities right and they can
like make people do things just by
suggesting that Jesus you could say had
powers like well I think that that's why
does the implication is giving all this
yeah this is coming from Scripture yeah
he's just showing to you this is what it
would really look like yeah yeah and
like I said I show you I think that's
what makes this movie so cool and like
so unsettling it's just it has just such
a strange concept yeah but when you
think about it you're kind of like now
that sort of makes sense you know what I
mean and I just and I just really like
the the kind of like grounded way that
he went about it like you said it's it's
supernatural but in a way it it seems
like it could happen because nothing is
like really all that fantastical no you
know what I mean so it's like it's a
really cool movie but I wanted to say
like a couple of things apparently the
the main actor that's in it that played
Peter Nicholas whose name was Tony
LoBianco
he was actually not the first guy that
was gonna be it was supposed to be
Robert Forester which I think might have
been pretty cool because he always
played kind of rumpled detective kind of
characters I've never the name of the
first version of
Christianity the Marcia Knights yeah it
was called the book of Marci own you
guys can look that up it was the first
version of the Old Testament yeah
there's even their first version of the
of the Bible it didn't have the the Old
Testament in it it was and it just had I
don't even think it had any of the
Gospels in it it was just a bunch of
Pauline epistles it might have had one
gospel yeah but there was no concept of
a jerk of a virgin birth in in Marcion
ISM I don't believe yeah maybe there was
but they believed it oh maybe maybe yeah
Marcy nism I think did but there was
there was a prototype before that too
where there was no virgin birth that it
was a celestial jesus only because
marzyong didn't didn't make the Pauline
epistles but the Pauline epistles
support a celestial Jesus one that was
never born
yeah so the way it phrases things and it
never asks any questions about and it
never even references gospel stories so
whoever wrote the Pauline epistles had
never read a gospel yeah so they didn't
those Christians didn't have any stories
about a Jesus ministry on earth it was
just something in heaven yeah this is
like really like I said this fascinating
[ __ ] with the stars so in some ways like
this movie kind of explores that yeah
sort of aspect of religion and like
myth-making and things like that so like
I said Robert Forester was supposed to
be the main lead but apparently he was
only on the set for a few days and him
and Larry Cohen had a falling-out
yes he got replaced with someone at
which I think Robert Forester had been
good in it like I said cuz he kind of
plays these rumpled detective characters
a lot particularly the 70s but in a way
I kind of like that they got a slightly
less known actor because it made him
seem more like an everyman type of
character and he he actually really did
a good job in this I thought another
thing too and this amused the [ __ ] out
of me and this was something that Larry
Cohen did a lot you see a lot of these
shots that he did I mean the
cinematography and this is actually
pretty nice and everything so all these
shots that he did around New York City
he didn't have a single permit to do any
of that [ __ ] and like as far as I know
the the thing
the st. Patrick's Day parade and
everything like that I think that was
really the st. Patrick's Day parade and
he was like filming like a dude like
shooting up the place and like he had to
just it's like guerilla filmmaking
that's how I would have done it well
yeah because it's expensive to get ya
know just get your phone or we're gonna
know where to make the scene yeah and
you have people going just the movies
just the movie standing around in the
background yeah I mean okay cause I know
just making a movie just reminded me of
like [ __ ] era would you shoot get
[ __ ] in 20 minutes and then you just run
it's good [ __ ] out here
yes but yeah so that's essentially what
Larry Cohen was doing which I thought
was really cool like badass so good I
mean yeah especially if you know that
and like watch the movie like
considering all the shots that he got I
was like kind of amazing how he shot
like out in the streets they just did
stuff and he didn't get caught New York
but it was you so much money well yeah
that's wool because they have to like
clothes off so many streets and all this
other kind of stuff and they don't want
to do that because of the traffic I'm
sure like you own that [ __ ] and shoot it
oh that's what he would do that was this
thing now and like I said this is on
shudder at the moment and if you have
shutter and you have not seen it there
is also a delightful documentary about
Larry Cohen called King Cohen and it is
also on shutter and I highly recommend
watching that because he is entertaining
as hell and he has all these [ __ ]
great stories like all the movies he
made like I said shoot him without
permits and because he what he shot most
of his movies in New York City because
that's where he grew up so it's just
it's really really entertaining and I
really recommend it yeah and check out
Marcia Marcia nism and the book of Marci
owned and Gnosticism and you'll see yeah
that's what this movie is talking about
yeah it's what the Greek interpretations
of all these spiritual writings most of
them don't don't survive anymore yeah
but you know some of them are in the
Bible well all of them are in the Bible
but there's a bunch of them that didn't
didn't survive and like I said don't go
into this expecting yes it has sci-fi
elements but don't go into it expecting
like a sci-fi movie it is mostly a
police drama like a police investigation
story that has like some sci-fi elements
at the end it's not even really I don't
even know if I'd call it a straight-up
horror movie although it has horror
elements also and some of the scenes are
like kind of creepy or unsettling but I
feel like
I feel like it's getting its due now
maybe it's like it didn't do very well
at the time it kind of got forgotten
about a little bit so a low-budget
trippy movie you don't you know me just
go see it for what it is but in the past
few years I've seen like a lot of lists
that put it on like their top 100 horror
movies are like you know it's on like a
lot of underage that's how they want or
predator or anything like that it's just
a [ __ ] weird it's a weird movie for
kind of like the hid wasn't it called
the hidden the one that had the one that
deal Cronenberg movie the one who was a
good one called the hidden was it the
one that they had the damn virus in them
well that was that was more than one
making shivers shivers no no that was
the parasites there was the one that
where they were became sick zombies yeah
that was um that was shivers I think
shivers wouldn't it yeah kinda looks
like that movie in a way well that yeah
it's like everything looked like that
the 70 it's just a movie you know what
this reminds me of two um extra yeah
okay it has that kind of like to it too
cuz extra kind of had that family drama
type thing but then also there's aliens
yeah but it wasn't like a special
effects fest or anything like that it
was kind of like a real almost like a
realistic sort of thing except for it
you know what I mean that one what extra
was a lot grosser cuz it didn't that guy
like but like a full grown man like bust
out of a woman's vagina and [ __ ] like
there's all kind of weird [ __ ] but then
if you liked Extro you'd probably like
this because the vibe of it is kind of
similar like this one isn't real gory or
anything like that but it just has some
creepy like unsettling scenes and the
concept of it is just so cool so I can
see it's kind of like a curiosity but
yeah so if you have shudder definitely
check it out and like I said check out
King Coen 2 which is the documentary
about him I think they have a couple of
his other movies on there they might
have Q the winged serpent on there too
but I'll have to watch that again at
some point but yeah so definitely go
check it out if you're a Larry Cohen fan